يتوزع الوجود العسكري التركي الشماليه
سوريا على نحو 192 نقطه عسكريه
في محافظات الحسكه والرقه وحلب وادلب
واللاذقيه وحماه وذلك وفقا لمركز الجسور
للدراسات تطلع القوات التركيه بعده مهام
اولها المراقبه والحفاظ على وقف اطلاق
النار وصد اي محاولات لتقدم ما تعرف بقوات
سوريا الديمقراطيه الى المناطق التي تسيطر
عليها قوات المعارضه السوريه المدعومه من
تركيا اذا تكتفي انقر بهذه النقاط
العسكريه بل تدعموا فصائل عده من المعارضه
السوريه تنضوي تحت الجيش الوطني السوري في
شمال العراق لدى القوات التركيه عشرات
النقاط العسكريه يتمركز معظمها في مناطق
عند مثل بعشيقه واربيل ودهوك وصوره هذه
النقاط تعملوا بالتفاهم مع الحكومه
العراقيه وحكومه اقليم كردستان العراق
بهدف حمايه الح تركيا من اي محاولات
للتسلل الى الاراضي التركيه من قبل عناصر
حزب العمال الكردستاني اضافه الى مساعده
قوات البيشمركه اذا ما طلب ذلك
[موسيقى]